Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today you are going to witness perhaps history
in the making. You see, we have some amazing new
results with OpenAI’s ChatGPT, which is an AI
assistant that has now passed a US law school
exam and is considered to be on the level
of a C+ student. What is perhaps even more
incredible is that it also passed coding interview
questions, particularly from Google and Amazon.
That sounds like one more step towards the
human-level intelligence for an AI that
just a few years ago, most people
thought will never be possible.
Now, I have bad news and good news. The bad news
is that these are not results from a rigorously
peer reviewed paper, so we can’t pop the hood
and look inside to verify these claims. However,
good news, ChatGPT also took
an MBA exam with a professor at
Wharton business school at the University of
Pennsylvania, and we have a paper for that,
so we can look at the exact questions and
answers it has given, and an evaluation of
those answers as well. And the results are I
think, incredible. In short, this work is an
amazing leap forward, it can do absolutely
magical things, and then, as we saw earlier,
fall on its face on the simplest questions.
Now, hold on to your papers, because overall,
it seems to be a B to B- MBA student. Which
sounds incredible, but it gets even better,
because ChatGPT is no ordinary student. ChatGPT
is not just a student that can answer a few dozen
questions a day. It is a student that can answer
more than 10,000 questions nearly instantly.
Don’t forget, it also knows about so much
more than just business administration,
it knows about physics, art,
programming, literature,
and can recall and build on a larger body
of human knowledge than any of us can.
Actually, let’s have a look at 4 more amazing
and recent examples of what it can do.
One, it can write a little computer game where
we can fly around in a little virtual world,
and we can even control the camera with our mouse.
Yes, ChatGPT is only capable of outputting text,
but there are ways to convert text information
into visual information. And one excellent
example of that is computer code. This computer
code can be compiled into a computer game.
And to get all this, we just need
to ask. In goes one text prompt,
and out comes a computer game.
Clearly, a very simple one,
but just imagine how incredible of a learning
tool this will be for a new generation of
Fellow Scholars. Some of which you will see
at the end of this episode. You’ll love it.
Two, it can also become an incredible personal
assistant. Look, it checks our e-mail, okay,
we expected that. Then, it tells us
how many unread emails we have. Okay,
we expected that too. And now…listen.
Whoa! It also summarizes the contents
of these unread emails. How cool is
that? A true AI personal assistant.
Three, here is a brilliant application that
ties multiple things together. For instance,
if it has enough knowledge to be an okay
law-student and it is also an amazing assistant,
then have a look at this. A personal
assistant that summarizes the terms and
conditions. We have all been asked to accept
a huge wall of legal text that no one reads,
and even if a poor soul is asked to read
it, that person has a very small chance of
actually understanding it. However, that
is no more. ChatGPT comes to the rescue
and makes these readable for ordinary
humans in a hurry. I absolutely love
this one. And it can summarize Youtube videos as
well. I wonder what it would say about this one.
Four, we can also create more incredible
combinations. For instance, we can ask
ChatGPT a question, and have it answer in
the style of our favorite people. Here,
this Fellow Scholar asked it to choose
from Ronaldo and Messi in the style of
Jesse Pinkman from Breaking Bad. Who is the
better footballer? I thought about reading
the answer to you, but you know what?
We can even have a different learning
algorithm clone the actor’s voice and use
it to answer himself. How cool is that?
And, plus one because I can never resist. Here,
it was asked to describe how a Scholar should
hold on to their papers, and the amount of
detail in the answer did not disappoint. And,
yes, you are seeing correctly, the author
was Chesto. Yes, THAT Chesto, the Legendary
Scholar who earlier, showed you the reference
motion for holding on to your papers properly.
And as promised, I would absolutely love to
show you a heartwarming message from some of
our younger Fellow Scholars. Look at this. The
message given with this image was as follows:
“My cute kids enjoying another two minute
papers episode over our weekly Saturday
lunch. Whenever you say "hold onto your
papers" they all slam a hand on the table.”
And…yes! They are indeed showcasing
the proper technique. Also,
look at those grins! Learning something
new and improving themselves while they
are eating healthy veggies.
Loving it. Go Mini Scholars!
I love my job talking about these papers, and
it is incredible to do it for such an amazing
and receptive audience like you Fellow
Scholars. I have to pinch myself every
day that I get to do this. Thank you so much!
And if you have similar ceremonies at home,
make sure to keep them coming either here or on
Twitter. What an incredible heartwarming message!
And, one more thing. Whenever you see these news,
always keep the First Law of Papers in mind. The
First Law Of Papers says that research is a
process. Do not look at where we are, look at
where we will be two more papers down the line. I
see so many examples of other people reading these
news and just thinking about what is now, not
what will be soon. So, what will be soon? Well,
two more papers down the line, I am sure that
it will know our preferences quite well and
will summarize emails and papers exactly the
way we like it. And it will be able to do so
much more. So, what do you think? What would you
use this for? Let me know in the comments below!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!